RYAN: Today, we're
talking about cloud summit
series, data analytics
skills, and IAM for Cloud SQL.
I'm Ryan.
And welcome to
this week in cloud,
where we serve you the
lowest latency news.
Register for our 2022
Google Cloud Summit Series
and be among the first to
learn about new solutions
across data, machine learning,
collaboration, security,
sustainability, and more.
You'll hear from experts,
explore customer perspectives,
engage with interactive demos,
and gain valuable insights
to help you accelerate your
business transformation.
Our first event is
coming up in April.
And you'll want to bookmark
the Google Cloud Summit Series
website for all the updates.
These days, companies must
deliver simple experiences
to be successful.
For many cloud
providers, this means
enabling tightly integrated
data offerings that
simplify the data delivery
process without losing
sight of the sophisticated needs
of the modern data consumer.
It begs the question, to stay
ahead of data cloud market
trends in 2022, should
data practitioners
invest their time in
specializing their data cloud
skill sets or instead invest
their time generalizing
their data cloud skillsets?
Check out the article
to learn more.
If you're responsible for
administering Cloud SQL
instances, securing
your databases
is one of your top priorities.
However, as your number of users
on your SQL instances grows,
you may find yourself challenged
to keep access locked down.
We're happy to announce
that Cloud SQL support
for IAM conditions is
now generally available.
IAM conditions are part of Cloud
Identity and Access Management,
or IAM, the service that Cloud
SQL and other Google Cloud
services rely on for determining
access to cloud resources.
Check out the blog
for the full post.
If you want to read more
about these announcements
or see a full list,
check out the link.
Any thoughts or ideas?
Leave us a comment or tweet us.
We'll see you in the cloud.